[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is ah darn West add the alley Hill
professor of history and global affairs
he is a scholar of modern international
and global history with a specialization
in the history of eastern Asia since the
18th century
professor West's ad has published
sixteen books most of which deal with
20th century Asian and global history
today we'll talk with him about his
forthcoming book Empire and righteous
nation 600 years of China Korea
relations
welcome professor West Bank it's great
to be you so let's begin with an
overview of the book tell us about him
so this is a book that started as a set
of lectures that I gave at Harvard two
years ago where I try to provide an
overview of the relationship between
China and Korea over a long period of
time to sort of try to get to the
essence of what that relationship it's
like so it started very much from the
idea of the centrality the significance
of that particular relationship today I
think whatever happens in the future
relations between China and Korea are
going to be pretty important sharing
national community and then I developed
it from there so this was actually a
case of working backwards in history so
starting with my interest in the
contemporary relationship and then
working working back and it ended up
being a book much more about history
than about a contemporary situation but
hopefully you know it will be an
opportunity to learn okay and so you
have done a lot of work on Asia
specifically why Korea and China what
led you to focus on that relationship so
two things really I mean one I mentioned
already
it's the contemporary significance of
relationship so everyone now is
preoccupied what's going to happen on
the Korean Peninsula we are concerned
about the North Korean nuclear program
and where that would be heading we're
concerned in general about security
relationships in Northeast Asia
so that was one starting point for this
noble Chinese
by far the most significant neighbor of
Korea but there was also a preoccupation
with how this has worked through history
so Korea is a small country bordering a
country that for most of its existence
has been an empire China in its various
imperial incarnations
and I was quite eager to try to find out
a bit more about how that relationship
had worked so for instance why was Korea
never incorporated into the Chinese
Empire why was it always distinct what
did it have a very clear specific
identification of being outside of the
important that's an interesting question
I think in the broad sense yes yes so
how did you do the research so this is a
book where I started by giving the
lectures and then I figured out how
little I actually knew about much of
this so then I did what I usually do
when I write a book I go back to reading
and in this case mainly what others have
written about these people who know the
different periods of the Sun of Korean
relations for a relatively brief period
which deals with the early 20th century
I also looked at some of the document
collections that are available and then
I spoke to a lot of people about their
work on the past but also people who are
dealing with sino-korean relations today
so I spoke with policymakers and
officials in Seoul and in Beijing and I
also gave an early version of these
lectures in both of the capitals so both
in Beijing and Seoul and had the
reaction from their scholars and their
officials so that was into the genesis
of the book and then I went back to
writing and hopefully did something that
was slightly different from what it was
when I first presented elections okay
and so when you gave your presentations
your lectures in China and Korea and
also when you were doing the research in
general did you come across anything
where you asked anything that surprised
you that you didn't expect Oh a lot I
mean I think particularly surprising
perhaps today I mean when you think
about the relationship now between China
and Korea it's the the mutual
preoccupation of people from these two
countries
of each other so China being a big
country a bit like the United States
right you can you you ask people about
relationship with other countries and
it's you know it's somewhere there but
it's not central to their heart it's not
quote part of the core identity of who
they are for many Chinese Korea is a
little bit different because it has been
unable for China for millennia it is so
close that young Chinese now who watch
South Korean television television
series of various homes their reaction
is these people are foreign but they
almost like us and that preoccupation I
think was a bit surprising to me how
close that relationship is seen as being
and on the Korean side in terms of
Chinese culture and the origins the
common origins were so in which I would
write quite a bit about in the book all
the Chinese and Korean culture ok so
let's talk about how the relationship
how Korea's relationship with China did
develop over the course of 600 years and
how it did remain separate from it right
so this book starts in the late 14th
century so it starts when China gets a
new empire the Ming which comes in and
take over sets up a new Chinese state
after the fall of the Mongol Gold Empire
and at the same time but for somewhat
different reasons Korea also gets a new
state formation and a new Kingdom called
the JA zone and it's very interesting
that this happens roughly at the same
time I think much of that has to do with
these bigger changes already mentioned
the collapse of the Mongol Empire
probably also changes that happens in
the broader East Asian region in terms
of trade in terms of environment but I
didn't try to follow the development of
these two states and how they influence
each other and what the relationship
between them is and I focus in
particular for that early period on the
cultural relationship so both of these
two states based themselves on confusion
or particularly or confusion
thinking so the renovation of a set of
ideas that came out of China more than
2,000 years ago and that we invigoration
of these ideas and these ideas are that
you know family is very important the
state is very important the state is the
big family you know and everyone is
looking at in terms of creating a good
society and good lives very hierarchical
very didactic in both societies this
gets an enormous influence through the
activities of the state but also because
it's embraced by large numbers at least
of the elite population so that's you
know where the starting point the
formative era of this early modern
relationship between China and Korea and
this is one of those points that I think
are really important for understanding
the relationship today that common
heritage okay which of course the whole
region shares to some extent but it's
particularly intense between China and
good so why do you think that China
never brought them into their of the
fold of their empire so I think there
are two main reasons why it never
happened the first one which I explore
in the book is the development of what
you could which is slightly
anachronistic term call Korea
nationalism so at least I argument in
the book at least from the late 16th
century there is a very clear Korean
identity which is connected to the
culture as it had developed during the
Ming in China but is still separate from
it it was pretty close
I argue building on the work of
historians of Korea that have worked on
this before very close to what in the
19th century in early 20th century in
Europe people called a nation that's
quite unique in many ways but that
identity is important and then secondly
I think on the mint side and later on
Qing Emperor took over from remaining in
the early 17th century there was this
idea of Korea as
a symbolic ally as a model ally in a way
a model vassal a state that aligned
itself with whatever power was in
control of China and therefore had to
some extent on the right to be separate
from it it didn't have to be disciplined
it didn't have to be brought into the
Empire and told by the Emperor you know
stop misbehaving live like us was there
a certain level of respect do you think
doctoring the two countries I think
there was a great deal of respect no of
course on the Korean side on the Chosun
side we'll always had to be very careful
living next to an empire is always
difficult and sometimes very dangerous
and I think the Korean leaders during
the shows on the state developed a
number of ideas about how they could
handle that relationship with the
Chinese empires with the Ming and later
on the G always be respectful but also
always be very cautious with regard to
how you dealt with the Empire next door
for instance the Koreans became masters
of knowing much more about the Empire
and the Emperor knew about them Wow they
were extremely good taking advantage of
the ritual visits that they carried out
so contribute missions to Beijing
figuring out what was important for the
Empire what was discussed there then
where you could put it in modern terms
you could say they were really good at
intelligence work and all of this was
reported back to Korea and therefore the
Korean Kings knew how to react when
different kinds of initiatives came out
of this Minnesota okay let's jump to
more modern times in the Korean War
what effect did that have on
international relations in Asia so I
think the Korean War which was plays a
very important role in this book
transformed international relations in
East Asia
just as it transformed the Cold War on a
global scale it militarized everything
it made the whole situation in Asia
between China and its neighbors of
course also the United States much more
difficult and and and much harder to
handle then wasn't been the case before
no I think that would still
in tensions they would even without the
Korean War it's very likely that we
would have had a division of Korea of
some so because that comes out of the
ideological divides that existed even
prior to 1945 okay but it militarized
everything and it made things so much
harder to to solve and and that's of
course the effects of which we are
living with right up to today right
right of course so is there anything
over the course of the 600 years that
we've learned through history that can
help with today's situation do you think
I hope there's quite a bit I mean I hope
that the book will contribute to that
you know I mean first of all mostly
understanding as we've touched upon
already of just how hard it is to live
next door to one of the world's mega
states I mean how you handle it I think
this is a challenge today for both parts
of Korea both North and South in terms
of developing especially as China Royces
in terms of International Affairs and
become more significant on a global
scale they have to figure out how do we
deal with that relationship how would do
we deal with it in terms of economic
aspects the political aspects the
military strategic aspects you know
although even the cultural and on this I
think there is a great deal of learning
that can be heard from history you have
to be very careful very cautious in
terms of how you do it but that on the
other hand you cannot live a life that
is based on excluding the Empire that is
next door it has to be brought in so
what are the big lessons I think Rome
history is that there won't be a
solution to the division of Korea which
I think is what is needed in order to
avoid the kind of security dilemma that
we have at the moment without a very
strong Chinese movement so China will
have to be an active participant in that
process a positive participant in the
process without it it is very unlikely
that it will succeed mm-hmm and why do
you think China needs to play that role
specifically and and how best for it to
do so well so two questions so indeed
the first one is simply because of the
location of China its significance in
terms of its economic growth and growth
in its power
as I show in the book this has always
been the case with exception of a few
periods in which honor has been weakened
avoided China has been the big guy in
that region right so you have to take
that into consideration when you find a
more positive solution the second one is
what I hope that China will be moving
towards which is a more positive
relationship to Korea as a whole and
first and foremost to South Korea and
China is come a long way I mean you know
less than a generation ago China and
South Korea were enemies now they trade
with each other they sometimes have
disagreements but there is a great deal
of respect younger Chinese for the
achievements in Korea economic
achievements but also an admiration for
what an open pluralistic society South
Korea actually so I hope that the
Chinese government will continue to move
along that linking what is going to
happen in terms of the relationship on
the Korean Peninsula
with the enormous gains that have been
made in South Korea that's the logical
development for the Chinese day to move
it but of course as we know there are
all the difficulties that not least of
historical of historical nature that
means that China is still linked to
North Korea in in ways that are not
always conducive for inter-korean
relations and talk about that
relationship a little bit more where is
it today
so China and North Korea are still
formal allies even though the Chinese at
times do not want to reflect on that
this is of course an historical issue
that comes out of the Korean War and
especially the way the Korean War ended
under Chien Qing under the new
leadership in China there has been more
of an underlining particularly over the
last two three years of an ideological
communality between China and North
Korea then both are led by communist
parties both have the intention of
building socialist states now almost
confess that if I look at what is
actually happening on the ground in
China North Korea I don't see those
similarities and I'm not so sure how
much China gains
except perhaps in terms of its influence
inside of North Korea to underline that
point so I'm not saying that it would be
in our interest
anyone else's interest which ought to
break off relations with North Korea I
think to some extent China has a
stabilizing road with regard to the no
but I also think it's very important for
Chinese leaders to understand where
their long-term interests are and that
is connected to the port of Korea that
has been making is enormous developments
in progress since I'm also curious to
know your thoughts on South Korea and
North Korea because of course with
President Trump trying to broker a deal
there there seem to be the two countries
coming closer together than they had
ever been in the past so what are your
thoughts on that phenomenon well I mean
so when it comes to the Trump
administration it's very hard to say
what's gonna happen from know I mean
there have been attempts which I view
positively of trying to pull North Korea
into a direct dialogue with United
States this is what the North Koreans
have been saying ever since the Korean
War ended and they wanted but so far the
results have been relatively limited at
the same time there is a parallel
process happening between the south and
the north
based on president moon's initiatives
which I think have more of a chance of
succeeding at least in the short run of
relaxing tensions between the north and
the south
this won't resolve the division but it
will lead us hopefully in the direction
of a reduction of tension so what I
really worry about with regard to Korea
it's not just the tension that exists at
the moment the problem with the
situation in Korea is that it could lead
to war I mean it's one of the few
situations on a global scale which could
easily by mistakes being made here or in
Pyongyang or in Beijing or in Seoul lead
to a cataclysmic war with consequences
for beyond anything that most of us
would regard as imagined and and that's
the reason why it's so important to try
to reduce tension now with the idea
being that at some point in the future
the two parts of Korea would come
together again in the United Korea which
has been the situation for almost all of
Koreans history since the time that ice
so in terms of you looking at the
history of this region do you think that
that could possibly be likely yes I
think Korea will be reunified at some
point I don't know the circumstances
under which it would happen no because I
hope it would happen sooner rather than
later but it's very rare in human
history if you look at it overall that
an artificially divided country and
particularly a country with that strong
a sense of national identity which I
talked about in the book remain divided
for a very long period of time now we
can explain why that has happened
historically and I try to do that in the
book but free to become I forever
phenomenon I think it's very very
unlikely so this is again often what
happens in history we say that something
cannot be achieved until it suddenly
happens and that's the lesson of course
from Europe after the Cold War it's also
the lessons that we draw in a number of
other historical cases going further
back there is something about something
that belongs together in a cultural
sense being being put back together when
the possibilities exist for doing that
domestically and internationally I'm
pretty sure that will happen in Korea as
well well that would be something to
look forward to for sure so we look
forward to your book and thank you so
much for being here with us today it's
been a great pleasure thank you for
having me
for more information about Professor
Westat and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
you